we are back with my culinary bestie chef
pilar veldas
and she's here with a delicious meal for
your family that only takes seven
minutes to make and to prove it to you
we've got a timer set and we're going to
start the minute and i'm going to say
right now paular what are we making
today okay so we all have our go-to easy
dinners right we have our stir fries our
egg dishes our sandwiches those are
great options
but sometimes you want to judge things
up a little bit so today we are making
steamed mussels
in a butter and dijon mustard sauce
it's like restaurant quality but only in
seven minutes as usual soon
i love restaurant quality in seven
minutes so the first thing that we have
in the pan over here is some olive oil
and butter and that's nice and hot and
melted and you're going to throw in some
chopped garlic and shallots and that's
going to be the base of your sauce
you're going to give that a good saute
you want a medium to high heat because
again seven minutes here we go season
that little salt and pepper
that's a little salt salt pepper
i love that so that's gonna go and then
you're gonna mix your white wine
dijon mustard how easy is that
give that a little good whisk i love a
whisk
mini whisk at that and you're gonna pour
it into the pan so what's gonna happen
there as soon as you pour it into the
pan it's gonna infuse with the garlic
and shallots and it's going to stop the
cooking so it's not going to burn that's
going to come up to a boil drew i would
throw the lid on there so it goes faster
and while we're waiting for that to come
up to well can you throw actually the
bread in the toaster oven i sure can now
i love the way people cut bread because
it makes a huge difference in the
pleasure and interaction of the sandwich
am i going to cut it this way like flat
and open yeah do you want to
keep it you could do that i'm also like
a throw it in the oven and then tear it
so it's nice and crusty also save some
time
i think if you do it on l one drew
that's gonna be fine so my sauce over
here is coming up to a boil and i'm
gonna throw in those mussels drew okay
because these are gonna take maybe three
to five minutes to cook fully and you
know the muscles are steamed
when they fully open so drew we're gonna
throw in your muscles i'm ready cover it
give that a good shake around
and then pop the cover on
and they're gonna steam for about three
to five minutes so while they're
steaming your bread is toasting and
let's chat mussels because i think a lot
of home chefs get a little intimidated
about using muscles and i really don't
think people should be because they're
incredibly simple to use and cook
i can't believe i'm actually seeing you
chop herbs i know you're so excited this
is probably like the one dish where i'm
like okay i'm going to bring my knife to
the party hilarious usually uh tears her
herbs by hand
and feels very sacred about not damaging
thy herb with too much knife work it's
so true
um so quick note about the muscles
really not intimidating great product to
use great source of protein nutrients
and they're actually one of the top
choices in terms of sustainability and
affordability so definitely keep that in
mind you want to make sure right before
you use them you give them a good rinse
and sometimes the muscles will come with
a little beard which is these uh like
tendril like things and you're just
gonna pull those off really easily and i
feel like for shopping for mussels the
most critical thing you want them to
smell like really fresh and clean like
they were just kissed by the ocean so
just a little bit of saltiness and if
any of the mussel shells are cracked you
definitely want to discard those don't
deal with those actually can i get a
time check because my muscles are
feeling pretty
open and cooked over here so every time
we say muscles i think people just need
to i also think my muscles are feeling a
little flabby actually
how are your muscles doing over there
because mine are open
mine are open and perfect and i'm going
to give that probably another 30 seconds
yeah
until all the muscles are fully open you
don't want to deal with any of the
muscles that remain closed or cracked so
just discard those would be not not
great to eat absolutely so that was 30
seconds drew do you want to grab your
bread
it all smells very good right now
beautiful
we just need more space
thank you you're welcome
and then the final thing to do with
these muscles actually look at that mine
are pretty good
they're perfect
a few more grounds
any salt
no more salt so
the mussels will have like an inherent
salinity so they give off this sweetness
and saltiness
inherent salinity a few grinds of black
pepper and then
a little bit of the freshly chopped
parsley
and you can actually serve straight from
the pot like this or
shimmy it into your serving bowl look at
all that beautiful songs
shimmying absolutely oh my gosh i have
to tell you i've always wanted to make a
dish like this
and you just made more parsley all
possible
[Music]
cheers
shall
you have to serve it with the bread
because that sauce is just like oh my
god so delicious
you're amazing
[Applause]
thank you so much go to the drewberry
thedrewberrymarshow.com for the full
recipe
i love this dish and i love you
[Music]